من احب الاشياء لدى ابو هيثم ان يتجول في
ازقه عين حوض جنوب حيفا قريته التي هجر
منها في النكبه فذاك ما ينسيه مشقه السفر
من مخيم نور شمس في الضفه الغربيه حيث
اصبح لاجئا يعرف كل زقاق وكل بيت هنا
واسماء سكانه الاصليين
يقودنا الى بيت عائلته الى حيث ترك ذكريات
طفولته يسكنه اليوم مستاجر اسرائيلي اسوه
بباقي بيوت القريه التي بقيت على حالها
وتحولت الى معارض ومراسم لفنانين
اسرائيليين انا يعني
يطلب ابو هيثم اذن للدخول الى داره
لم يكن وجودنا هنا مرغوبا فيه
او ربما يكون مستفزا لمن عرف ان القادم هو
صاحب الدار ان يظهر سيدي لا اريد ان
تصورني يعرف ابو هيثم انه يقف على عتبه
داره بقوات الحق ويتمنى ان يكون هو في
الداخل بدلا من الغريب الموجود فيها بحق
القوه كما يقول والله متذكر
هون باب الباب هذا
ممتلكات الفلسطينيين من الامور المؤلمه
فقد نهبت العصابات الصهيونيه والجيران
اليهود كلما نالت وايديهم من اثاث وحولي
ونقود وحتى مكتبات خاصه في بيوت المهجرين
كل شيء يمكن ان يحمل
احنا انه الناس ما اخذت كل اغراضها هذا
واضح فكان من السهل خلع الابواب والدخول
الى البيوت و فيها كامل الاثاث يكشف
الارشيف الاسرائيلي عن قوائم للمسروقات
وعن شكاوى تقدم بها الفلسطينيون لاستعاده
ممتلكاتهم فيما يبدو انها كانت عمليه نهب
تعمدت القياده السياسيه الاسرائيليه انذاك
صرف النظر عنها
من وجهه النظر بينغوريون كان هدم القرى
وسيله لمنع عوده الفلسطينيين الاهم كان
تجنيد اليهود لذلك عبر نهب ممتلكات
الفلسطينيين لجعل اليهود شركاء في الجريمه
التي ارتكبها في الاساس الجنود
والى جانب الممتلكات الخاصه استولت
اسرائيل على اهم مقدرات الشعب الفلسطيني
كميناء حيفا ومعامل تكرير البترول وشركات
وصناعات وورش ما زالت الى اليوم تشكل مركز
ثقل الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
تعرضت فلسطين خلال النكبه الى اكبر عمليه
سطو في التاريخ المعاصر بحسب كثير من
المؤرخين ومن الصعب حصر حجمها او تقديرها
بثمن ذلك انها تمثل بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
خساره بحجم فداحه فقدان وطن باكمله
مدينه حيفا